no my name is bring something if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now Brooks and I have made an
attempt to review of Grammy's fashions
last night but we were not in the right
state of mind
squeezed together I'm with you oh yeah
miss Brooks if you didn't know that you
didn't know it now okay uh Oh God
we've been watching WWE Royal Rumble
until were too excited and also Brooks
got hives but we're here now and we're
doing it live on tape and then edited
and then uploaded and all very prepared
let's get into some Grammy fashion
reviews reviewing perfect
Alessia Cara this is great look we go
recently divorced dad going out for the
first time an older brother at his
younger sister's wedding that won't go
full suit but I'll make an attempt I
love it cute
Julia Michaels wow this is like a very
Punk Cinderella like you're Cinderella
but your fairy godmothers like Kat Von D
cute Zane hi this day and always look
like he's trying to communicate pain
anguish or just confusion with his
eyebrows looks like he's watching an
ex-lover walk away for the first time
yeah Miley Cyrus I just I love Miley
Cyrus more and more and more and more
this new evolution of her I'm a big fan
of she looks like a very sensitive
romantic dominatrix and I love it cute
pink wow I love pink and this looks like
snuffleupagus was going to an EDM
concert and it took all the ecstasy and
it you know what had a great time cute
Heidi Klum there she is she made it our
girl made the Grammys I feel relieved
this is very like the Victoria's Secret
granny golf you party B oh my god I
don't care to be so much and I love
everything about this you know that
movie Donnie Darko and like the
time-space continuum like bubble like
chemtrails come out of his body this
kind of looks like that and undress for
and you know what it's perfect this is
very Bjork's Swan dress meets 80s
bridal fashion
and I love it you Katie Holmes what are
you doing there and how is what alright
this is very sexy and cool and
interesting and kind of looks like when
you know seniors in high school make
their prom dresses up duct tape here loo
chrissy teigen god another human i just
love and you're making another human
inside of your cool human body already
like nature rules when that happened
like if i look back at a photo of my mom
and like this is the photo of that i saw
I'd be like
the food am I supposed to do with my
life Rita Ora this is beautiful your
body looks amazing I like all the swoosh
in the swoops and all of it this looks
like when I try and like erase things in
Photoshop but I don't do it correctly
and I just kind of you know like that
cute Camila Cabello I feel very 80s vibe
from all of these gowns and outfits you
know disco ball Tamagotchi
first thing happening cute and ruching
in a new spot that I didn't know ruching
could be and ruching is like when the
fabric bunches so it helps make like
your midsection look slimmer but she's
going for ruching on the hip joints get
it girl we mount them thigh socket cute
Hailee Steinfeld Steve Joyce turns Dean
Dean Stearns Dean feasting feel the [ __ ]
what is this you've got 2018
- but Crest toothpaste it's like your
top half is very classic and then your
bottom half is like black mirroring
swirl curtain and coming out from the
future you guy corks in Oh Gothic
Renaissance skews you is this what that
makes Dallas I haven't read or watched
it but I assume it's like oh bonnets
cute Kesha ah you look like a business
cowboy that likes to party and I love it
Clint Eastwood meets John Travolta meets
Barbie
no no that is that may be some stuff but
outfit was cute Sam Smith where did you
go you look great good for you a green
suit
Donald Glover oh dang it I don't like
her I love her hate myself but cute Anna
Kendrick what sexy fancy future 80s law
firm does everyone work out how do I get
an interview this is like sex in the
city meets wolf of wallstreet me it's
like kind of the monopoly man regardless
cute Janelle Monae my this is I might be
my favorite look of the whole night I'll
love to no Monday and this just is so
good it's like you're a butler in Narnia
and I love everything about it
yeah Lana Del Rey like a walking
snapchat slash Urban Outfitters
campaign yeah Lady gaga look you did it
you did it and you did it you look like
a madam of the coolest brothel ever
beautiful cheap breathable cumbersome
high-fashion and the back your head
looks like a cool sneaker on someone
with cankles you're doing it you're
nailing that good job cute okay that's
it for my Grammys fashion review I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
make sure to subscribe to this YouTube
channel I'm making videos Tuesdays and
Thursdays technically but this doesn't
make that seem true also click that Bell
notification so you know when I upload
because it clearly is all over the place
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up let me know in the comments down
below who you love the Grammys obviously
I missed a ton of really will just
beautiful people that are very talented
doing cool interesting fun Thanks so let
me know other than that I don't know
Jayden Smith yeah you did it this is
like very floor of the workroom and
Project Runway chic meets like stepdad
shoes you